thank you shelter you're welcome
Zelda seems subtly hostile to me this
week how do you figure the way she
served the potatoes yours she served
gently mine she slapped down like we're
in Attica
that is an actor Tony salou and the
marvelous
Hazel now he's starring in a new movie
It's called Flamin Hot it is out this
week it's about Rick Montanez who helped
make Flamin Hot Cheetos one of the most
popular snacks in the world shalu plays
the CEO who green lights it watch this
my family my neighbors they can't get
enough and I got a plan Mr Enrico to get
it to the streets to get to my people I
think it 'll save our Factory and we'll
save jobs
save jobs huh
that's a lot of confidence there Richard
yes sir and you said in the video think
like a CEO
so I did
you saw my video yes sir
and you're a janitor maintenance Cruiser
like look if it's okay I'd like to send
you some samples Sir Richard
that's more than okay with me
Tony salub is here good morning good to
see you love this movie love this story
love everything about it um but the
question I always ask actors you you are
known obviously for monk you're known
for Mrs marvelous Mrs maisel
um I saw you in the band's visit on
Broadway it was incredible uh but what's
it like playing a fictional character
versus a real life person
well uh you know obviously you're uh
you're always relying on the writers to
a certain extent but with uh with a real
character you can do a deep dive in into
your own you know research and kind of
find the connections between uh the
character uh the the non-fictional
character you're doing in your own life
for example with with this with um you
know with with Enrico you know I um I he
was from a small town in the midwest
coincidentally and so was I and kind of
humble beginnings and made a uh you know
a a huge a huge success in his life so
you know there were certain there were
certain connections there
um and this this movie you know with his
family and with the Montana's family
they're both kind of immigrant stories
so there's the connection there yeah you
know the other thing that I liked about
the movie I didn't know this until the
credits I always didn't watch the
credits Eva Longoria that made her
directorial debut yes so tell us about
working with her on the set
amazing and the kind of set she runs
because I can't imagine how she was Siri
goodbye does this ever happened to you
with a watch you all of a sudden goodbye
to know about Eva Longoria yeah
well yeah Eva was great I actually uh
was movie was probably uh a four or five
week shoot and um my part was the they
kind of put myself all toward the end of
the shoot so by the time I got there I
think it was the last week pretty pretty
sure and uh boy it was that crew was so
devoted to her she just had this
atmosphere uh fostered that was she got
a sense of the the set the tone that she
said absolutely just just productive and
these people have been working really
hard because it was an ambitious
schedule that they had you know it was a
sort of an independent film there and uh
they were just even though they were you
know pushing to the end the the vibe was
so good they were devoted to her I had a
I had a wonderful time with this crew
and she was so
at ease it was felt like she had been
doing this her whole life speaking of
pushing that yeah go either uh I'll take
this question unless Siri has wants to
jump in again I know it's annoying I'm
just joking uh speaking of pushing to
the end uh marvelous Mrs maisel uh Fifth
and final season uh your character Abe
Weissman iconic in my household lines
are repeated uh what's it like saying
goodbye difficult
um we uh we really you know we really
knew we had a rare thing there
the cast The Crew the creative team got
really really close and uh
we you know these These are these kinds
of things don't come along that often
where all the stars align and uh and the
Arca your character too Tony from the
beginning to now right you know so often
in TV you know you can sort of you get
on a if if something is long running you
can kind of get pigeonholed into one uh
you know one area but they just they
just they served all of these characters
so beautifully the writers did
um and especially Abe I felt the ark was
complex and gratifying and uh and and so
we're gonna miss it yeah you took some
mementos with you yeah
did you did you grab a mentor from set
um I actually I I didn't grab okay
I don't I don't know
well I'm excited that you Monk is one of
my favorite yes I know we have to go but
you just got him back with monk I can't
wait right we just finished shooting
that and uh it's gonna come out in
November I think streaming on peacocks
we love it uh Tony salute thank you very
very much flaming hot can be streamed
this Friday on Hulu